the most powerful Cyclone to hit the Bay
of Bengal in the last 10 years is
crossing the coast of Bangladesh and
Myanmar strong winds and rainfall caused
by the category 5 storm has forced
hundreds of thousands of people to move
to safer areas nearly a million rocking
gear living in refugee camps in Cox's
Bazaar are in the storm's projected path
Aid agencies say they're preparing for a
major emergency response time for
Chargers got more
Bangladesh has been spared the main
threat of the Cyclone mocha by the time
it made landfall here somewhere around
745 GMT to 8 GMT the wind speed was
barely 120 kilometer per hour and you
can still see the wind is still on it's
the peripheral wind and heavy rain it
hit the San Martin island to some
damages one person was still there by
falling tree that's an unconfirmed
report by our contact from journalists
staying there there's been some damage
on shop for Dave nearby as for the
rohingya camp we know there's been no
major damages our contacts said to you
have sweat damage they're already
repairing it there was no Landslide or
flood so they also have been spared from
the thrust of this Cyclone now the
government and the rescue and Red Cross
and others gonna assess the damage it
may take a couple of days or even weeks
because many of the fishermen lives in
scattered islands in the coastal areas a
lot of the people who live in the
coastal areas are in the shelter the
most likely will lose all their
aquaculture farmland and other crops
those are major damage for the poor
people living by the coastline it takes
months and years for them to get back on
their feet unless they get help from the
government and other Aid agencies we yet
have to see what are the real damage
within next few days or even weeks